there's lots of times in your life
you're not going to be happy and so
that's not gonna work you want to have
something meaningful that's the boat
that will take you through the storm
[Music]
well here we are with Jordan Peterson
and I could not be more excited to talk
with the best-selling author of twelve
rules for life and I will talk with him
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at helix league so there's
nobody on the planet like you so why
would you buy a mattress built for
everyone else working with the world's
leading sleep experts helix sleep
developed a mattress that's customized
your specific height weight and sleep
preferences so you can have the best
sleep of your life at an unbeatable
price here's how it works you go to
helix sleep calm fill out their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll design
your custom mattress they even customize
each side for you and a partner in 2018
helix sleep has taken customized sleep
to the next level with their helix
pillow it really is fantastic their only
pillows are fully adjustable so you can
achieve perfect comfort regardless of
sleep position or body type helix sleep
has thousands of five-star reviews plus
you get a hundred nights to try them out
go to helix sleep calm slash been guest
right now and you'll get up to 125 bucks
toward your mattress order that's helix
sleep calm slash been guest for up to
125 dollars off your mattress order
again that's helix sleep calm slash bed
and guests get the deal with Ben guests
and make sure that they know that we
sent you okay so I could not be more
excited to speak with Jordan Peterson
well as Jordan knows before the show we
talked for an hour before the show just
about interesting things we should have
caught on tape but now we're actually
gonna get a chance to do it live so here
is the Jordans new book if you haven't
bought it yet everybody on planet has
bought this book I was walking through
the office today we didn't have a copy
in the office the person to front desk
had a copy your book just sitting on
your desk so that's the way this works
twelve rules for life in antidote to
cast fantastic book obviously topping
all the bestseller lists all over the
world Jordan thanks so much for joining
the show really appreciate it thanks for
the invitation well you know obviously
your your prominence has just blown up
in the last year and a half when we were
talking before the show about why that
is and why there are so many people who
suddenly are very angry about you I
noticed there was an article in Politico
suggesting that young angry white males
you are now their their leader so
congratulations oh yes I want to ask you
about that why do you think that number
one your profile has become so big of
late and number two why do you think it
is that so many members of the of the
left are so angry about that why are
they characterizing people who listen to
you as angry enraged
well we could we could look at the
characterization to begin with you know
because I think it speaks to the
pathology of the radical left instantly
they're absolutely incapable of viewing
the world except through group identity
terms you know and so if someone comes
out and disagrees with them then they
have to characterize them by their
fundamental group attribute whatever
that happens to be maybe its gender
because that's a favorite or maybe it's
race and so angry white men young there
we go
sexist ageist and racist all at once
right they're angry young white men well
it has to be that way if you're going to
be the if you're gonna play the leftist
game because that's the only way that
you can look at the world and then if
you can't make your opponent
reprehensible in some manner and it's
strange that they would attempt to make
them reprehensible on the grounds of
race age and sex sense that's precisely
what they stand against hypothetically
but if you can't make your enemy
reprehensible along some dimension then
you have to contend with them seriously
and so you know if I'm not an all right
fascist like Hitler you know or my low
you know polis which was how I was
characterized in Canada because the
radical leftist can't even get their
bloody insults straight
he's like Hitler or Milo you know Poulos
it's like because there's no difference
between them right no obvious difference
it's just another attempt to Hillary as
far as I can tell and I think that it's
it's dreadful I really think it is there
was an article written in by the I
believe the editor of the New York
Review of Books that was just
republished in The Globe and Mail
talking about the emergence of hyper
masculinity and how I was somehow
responsible for that or contributing to
it like Mussolini and I read that and I
thought yeah like miscellany and I
thought okay so what are you doing I see
you're you're defining masculinity or
conflating masculinity and hyper
masculinity at the same time then your
virtue signaling by being against hyper
masculinity but really what you're
trying to do is bring down whatever it
is that's masculinity and what
masculinity is in in this frame is
something like competence and so it's
part of the radical leftists general war
on competence as well which I think is
one of the most pernicious elements of
the culture wars that is
lucien of hierarchies the the assumption
that every hierarchy has to be based on
power and served them the needs of your
group whatever that happens to be that
there's no such thing as confidence and
so and then the other thing that's
reprehensible about it because that's
not enough is that it's just wrong
like there's I've got tens of thousands
of letters from people and people come
up to me all the time on the street I'll
give you an example this is a great
story this is really touching so I was
in LA about a month and a half ago and I
was downtown LA and Downtown LA's kind
of rough and I was wandering around and
with my wife and this young guy pulled a
car up beside he hopped out and he was
kind of a stylish looking 21 year old
Latino guy something like that it was
all excited he said he asked me who I
was and I told him and he you know
that's what he had presumed and so he
was kind of excited about that he said
look I've watched all your lectures and
it's really helped me and I've been
straightening out my life and trying to
get my room clean and he laughed about
that but you know developing some aims
and trying to tell the truth and and
look I've really fixed up my
relationship with my father and so then
he said wait wait just wait a minute and
I thought sure what sure so he went back
in the car and he God is farther out of
his car and he came over with his dad
like they had their arms around each
other and he said look we've really
improved our relationship and they're
both smiling away and you know that's
man if you're gonna target me for that
just go right ahead and as a relay
supremacist oh yeah yeah and it's
wherever I go now and this is one of the
things this is the thing that's so
wonderful about that all of this as far
as I'm concerned is that people come up
to me all the time and that's exactly
what they say they say look I was lost
aimless depressed nihilistic anxious
drug-addicted
alcoholic wasting my time masturbating
too much although they don't generally
use that particular example you know
loss essentially and and and hopeless in
some sense and I've been watching your
lectures and they've really helped and
I've really been putting my life
together and I've been trying to say
what I believe to be true and develop a
vision and it's really helped and like
and it's so overwhelming you know like
if I'm doing book signings after a talk
then there'll be a dozen people or more
who and these aren't like I'm only
talking to people for about 15 seconds
but you can have a very intense
conversation in 15 seconds and they'll
say look you know like I was suicidal
man like I was really hanging on to the
edge of the earth by my fingernails and
I'm better and they have tears in their
eyes it's like it's amazing little of
that goes a long way well I think that
when I look at your eyes and look I talk
to people who love what you do I mean
every time I go on the road and I'm
speaking at a campus you're the number
one name that gets mentioned that people
would by people who come to my lectures
and I think that the reason for that
that I've that I've seen is is really
twofold one is that one of the things
that you really talk a lot about is the
notion of self discipline and purpose in
your life and control and the idea that
you are in control of your
decision-making and your decision-making
matters that's one and the other
reserves you have you have a unique
capacity to say no to things and when
somebody says something to you that is
illogical but popular then you have the
capacity to say no that's what happened
in that Kathy Newman interview that then
somebody was saying something to you
that made no sense and you just said
well no and then you just stood on that
now and when you stand on that no I
think it gives people a lot of courage
yeah well I mean the the gender issue is
really an interesting one because one of
my professional domains of expertise is
individual differences I'm a personality
psychologist and so I know the gender
difference literature and it's it's a
very solid literature well first of all
it's very solid it has a 30-year history
once per psychologist got the
personality models down so that would be
the big five model all empirically
derived straight statistics right brute
force empiricism nobody had a
theoretical axe to grind with the big
five except to say maybe there are human
traits maybe they're encapsulated in
language we can use statistical
techniques to find out what they are
that was it that is the whole ideology
so very very neutral as far as
ideologies go five traits emerge okay
are there differences between the sexes
turns out there are all right they're
not massive although if you sum them
across all the traits you can separate
men and women with about 75 percent
accuracy so it's not trivial but you
have to sum across all the traits then
another question comes up well are those
differences socio-cultural or
biologically okay we can test that we'll
go around the world we'll look at
cultures will rank order them in terms
of the gender equality of their
sociological policies we can do that
with broad agreement from the right and
the left then the hypothesis would be if
gender differences decrease among more
egalitarian societies then the gender
differences are socio cultural or at
least more socio-cultural that's exactly
the opposite of what was found
repeatedly that's pseudoscience it's
like no that's mainstream psychology
those papers have thousands of citations
and write the average humanities paper
has zero citations right and then the
next most common one has one 3,000
that's an that's an unbelievable classic
and and here's the other bit of fruits
like you say well how do you know that
you can trust someone's judgment about a
fact the fact emerges despite their
ideological presuppositions okay so it's
well known that the social sciences and
the humanities have a have a left tilt
and a lot of that Stamper mantle and the
tilt has become more pronounced but as
Jonathan Hyde has pointed out there are
no conservatives among social
personality psychologists or none to
speak of here yes very few vanishingly
feeling and if the field has a bias it
is definitely and indisputably a
left-wing bias okay so you have to fight
that if you're if you're a scientist
right even if you're left-wing scientist
you have to fight that because you want
to get to the facts it was these social
scientists who generated the data that
suggested that the gender differences
not only were real but that were bigger
in egalitarian societies they didn't do
that to grind their ideological axe
because their ideological presupposition
was no no you make the society you
latarian men and women get more of the
same it's like no they get more
different Oh Ruth isn't that something
and so then there's a corollary there
which is all right you could still say
and they're kind of pushing in this
direction in Scandinavia boys and girls
are different men and women are
different
it looks biological but because people
are malleable you could push
the socio-cultural structure harder and
harder to minimize the biological
differences okay well first of all maybe
and maybe not maybe you'd get a rebound
and they'd get even like the kids would
rebel that could easily happen but let's
say okay you could the problem with that
is is that if you seed that much power
to the state like you're basically
giving the state the right to socialize
your kids rights like you you really you
really you really want to do that I mean
people in Israel couldn't do that with
the kabuto right it didn't work so
people aren't gonna give up their
children to the state and thank God for
that well I mean this is one of the big
questions that we were discussing
earlier is that we were talking about
the polarization in politics between
right and left and obviously you're
you're a psychologist you're a
philosopher but you've been dragged
almost kicking and screaming into this
political sphere because everything has
been so politicized and so when you say
when you cite social science statistics
and they're scientifically based you're
called a racist you're called the sexist
you're called the homophobe and exactly
so so why is it that so why do you think
it is that so many folks on the Left who
purport to be all about reason and
science and an objective fact are so
willing to throw those out the window
the minute that it becomes politically
inconvenient well because you imagine
that cognitive system so an
interpretation of the world has levels
there axiomatic levels some fundamental
presuppositions are more fundamental
than others and you could say well the
leftists historically maybe because of
their atheistic rationality are more on
the side of science than say the
fundamental isms of any sort but when
push comes to shove you find out how the
axioms are are nested there's deeper
axioms underneath that which is that all
hierarchies are based on power and all
power plays are based on group identity
tribal identity essentially and that the
entire history of the world is nothing
but a power play between between these
different identity groups it's like okay
well if the science indicates that some
of that's wrong then do you alter those
beliefs or do you alter the science and
the answer to that question is well it
depends on how you
hierarchically arranged those if the
science is at the bottom then you alter
your beliefs right if it's the
scientific facts or the axiomatic some
structure then you then you alter your
beliefs if your beliefs are the
axiomatic sub structure then you alter
the science well we've seen how that
plays out and one of the things I've
tried to do so to speak is to diagnose
the axiomatic structure it's like ok
what's the what's the metaphysical
presumption structure of the radical
left well what what it is is you're
basically your group your groups are
basically engaged in warfare right and
the warfare is arbitrary except insofar
as it serves your group ok I don't buy
any of that I think that's I think
that's a route to certain disaster I
think it's a degeneration into tribalism
and that we will seriously pay for it
not only because it returns us to
tribalism and tribes fight as the
anthropological evidence for that is
overwhelming right tribes fight it
doesn't even matter if they're
chimpanzee tribes even chimpanzee tribes
fight so not only do you regress to a
tribalism but you also invalidate the
one proposition that's being able to
help us arise above the tribal which is
the idea that the individual should be
sovereign and so I think the culture war
is about what's the proper framework
within which to view human identity and
what's the relationship between the
individual and the group in relationship
to that identity and the leftist answer
is it's all group and it's all power
it's like okay so in just a second I
want to ask you a little bit about is
some of the some of the more
enlightenment minded thinkers who are
out there right now because it seems
like we've been discussing the big gap
in in Western civilization right now
which is between the collectivists and
the individualist if you're broadly but
I want to talk about some of the
divisions among the individualist in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Birch gold so
with the uncertainty of the of the
market right now with all of the
volatility a lot of Americans are
increasingly concerned about the
security of their savings and the
Federal Reserve obviously has a loose
monetary policy it's been shoring up
recently but there's a lot of volatility
in the markets well this is the reason
why I need to talk to my friends over at
Birch gold so virtually
komm is the place to go if you want to
put some of your assets in precious
metals yeah I'm not saying take all of
your money I did stock market and
pushing and precious metals that'd be
stupid but you should have a little bit
in precious metals to hedge against
inflation and volatility in the markets
Birch gold sells physical precious
metals for your own possession they'll
ship metal right to your front door and
right now thanks to an IRS tax law you
can even move your IRA or eligible 401k
into an IRA backed by physical gold or
silver if you so choose it's a good
option for people who want to ensure
that their retirement savings are
protected from the possibility of
inflation or stock market volatility
Birch gold group they have a really good
long-standing track record of continued
success they've been advertising with me
for years thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau ask all
your questions about precious metals
investing get all your answers and then
contact Birch gold group to request a
free information kit on physical
precious metals their comprehensive 16
page kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move that IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA if
that's something you're interested in
thinking that no class no obligation kit
head over to birchgold.com slash bed
that's birchgold.com slash burn that
also wants to know that we sent you
okay so Jordan one of the things that
we've been talking about obviously is
the big gap that I think we certainly
agree on between the the collectivists
identity politics and and the
sublimation of science in favor of
subjective politics that favors a power
group but I want to talk a little bit
about a division that is is also now
breaking out among those of us who I
think would consider ourselves friends
in the Enlightenment so you consider
yourself a friend of the Enlightenment
style thinking at least in the essence
that individuality matters and at the
individual is sovereign the scientific
matters read data matters are useful
exactly and and in this group you know I
consider myself as part of this group
people have started to call it the
intellectual dark web sam harris is part
of this group there they're a wide
variety of folks with a lot of broad
political differences that are part of
this group but there are some real
differences that are broken out even
among people who consider themselves
part of this group right steven pinker
it has a different perspective on the
world then then you do I have a
different perspective than sam Harris
does you and I have our differences
probably on some matters of philosophy
so where do you think the vulnerability
lies in the in the possibility of
revivifying enlightenment mentality
because it seems
me that one of the big problems that's
that's popping its head up above the
water now is the rejection of the
Enlightenment in favor of this old-style
tribalism that you've been talking about
that we're now going to repeat history
because we benefited so much from the
Enlightenment that we forget that things
don't have to be this way we've got so
much nice stuff we live in so much
freedom that we forget that if we just
toss those Enlightenment ideals out the
window things get really ugly again I
think that's what unites well that
that's the question is that what what
what do you toss out the window before
things get ugly right and the
Enlightenment proponents you could say
Harris you could say Pinker Charles
Taylor in Canada they trace back the
development of the modern self let's say
Taylor wrote a book called sources of
the modern self to the Enlightenment and
it's quite interesting because like if
you look at the typical academic
psychologists say their historical
knowledge generally runs back about 15
years and so because they are all
concerned with the with the modern
literature and there's some utility in
that but that the downside is they don't
have any historical context so you read
someone like Taylor and you think wow
he's stretching it back 500 years you
know but there's there's reading that
goes way beyond that to look at the
sources of the self and the source of
the modern ethos and this is a huge bone
of contention between people like me say
and people like Harris and I think
between people like you and people like
Harris is that my sense is that the
Enlightenment values themselves are
grounded in an ethos that's much deeper
and much less articulated and that would
be an ethos of metaphor image drama
ritual religion art music all of that
dance even for that matter the nonverbal
the the pattern recognition ian
McGilchrist has written a book called
the master and his emissary which lays
that out white knight nicely with
regards to hemispheric specialization
it's kind of predicated on Alcoa and
Goldberg's observation that the left
hemisphere is specialized for what we
know and the right hemisphere is
specialized for what we don't know so
that's an order chaos dynamic and the
rough idea would be that the left
hemisphere generates paradigm attic
systems so that would be like the
Enlightenment system actually imprinted
right even stainable axiom predicated
but that that entire XE ematic system is
based in a nonverbal in the nonverbal
domain that's associated with while it
would be associated with the right
hemisphere but it would also be
associated with deep motivations
biological motivations and emotions and
so because here's one way of looking at
it you think well how do you validate an
axiomatic system of ethics and the
answer is quite straightforward Jean
Piaget figured this out is you play it
out in the world literally you act it
out in the world and then you watch each
other's emotional responses and if the
thing that you're playing out is the
axiomatic system that you're playing out
satisfies the motivations and the
emotions of the people who are engaged
in that system then the system is
justified and then you say well it's not
just that their motivations and emotions
are satisfied it's more complex it's
that the motivations and emotions of
each individual are satisfied but not
only now but now next week next month
and next year so you have to extend it
across time and not only my emotions and
motivations but yours as well now next
week next month and across time so this
there's terribly tight constraints they
are placed upon an hour an axiomatic
systems validity now the way Jean Piaget
thought of that he said well think about
it like a child's game a bunch of kids
get together and they decide to play
pretend okay and pretend is let's model
the world right and and as a place to
act because to pretend you ever do'
right so the kids get together and they
assign roles and they say well you're
gonna be mom you're gonna be dad you're
gonna be the dog and we're gonna play
house and then they they act it out and
what they're doing is seeing if they can
regulate the manner in which they're
constructing the game so that everyone's
emotions and motivations are so well
satisfied that they want to continue the
game okay and so that's so cool so what
it shows you is that's how an ethical
system is is tested and justified it's
like you play it out and you see if
everyone wants to keep playing and so
that's a whole different methodology
than the scientific domain right so the
axiomatic system isn't
the ethical axiomatic system isn't
justified by reference to the scientific
method it's justified by reference to
the emotional and motivational
well-being of all the players of the
game now that game emerges this is the
second part of this and this is so cool
then the question is well how does that
game emerge and the answer is the same
way that children's games emerges
so what Piaget noted is that kids would
get together and they'd play marbles and
if they were young kids they could all
play marbles say six six years old they
could all play marbles and and if they
were in a group they were playing
marbles and it all worked out fine
squabbles and all that but you know the
kids would keep playing right validating
the games but if you took the kids out
of the game and you said what are the
rules of the game they would give
completely disparate account so they
knew how to do it it was like the wisdom
was in the group mm-hmm the wisdom was
fragmented enough among the individuals
so if you pulled the individuals out
they'd give disparate accounts but if
you put them all together they could
play the game but then if you waited
till they were 11 or 12 and you pulled
them out of the game then they could
tell you the rules then at 14 or 15 they
they would be willing to this is with
more sophisticated games they would be
more willing to regard themselves as
makers of the rules okay so here's how
it happens in an evolutionary sense
people going all the way back to our
primate forebears organize themselves
into functional hierarchies okay and now
the hierarchies are complex and they're
not just based on power despite what the
idiot Marxists say even to do all has
noted that chimpanzee hierarchies are
unstable if they're only based on power
they don't last they may generate into
violence so you have a hierarchy that's
that works but it's acted out no one
knows why it works it works because
everyone seems to be happy with it okay
and so those hierarchies get more
complex and more sophisticated and then
people start to observe them and talk
about them it's like well we've got this
hierarchy here what's it like and then
they spin off dramas about the hierarchy
here's a hero who climbed up the
hierarchy and here's what a hero looks
like okay so then you get the idea of
hierarchy and then you get the idea of
the hero as the person who moves up the
hierarchy and generates it okay then out
of that
you get the extraction of the idea of
the hero and then you get development of
that idea and it's out of that you get
the monotheistic religions and so it's
like the procedure and the hierarchy
come first no one knows what the rules
are
it's all played out the same way that
wolves play it out in a pack or
chimpanzees play it out in a troop then
we wake up and think oh we live in a
structure mm-hmm here's the structure
that would be Osiris in the Egyptian
mythologies here's the structure here's
how the structure goes wrong here's what
the structure does here is it's tarin a
tyrannical aspect here's what you have
to do to generate the structure and to
thrive in it okay that's even more
important the hierarchy is important
enough what we want to know is how to
master the hierarchy okay that's where
you get the mythologies of the hero okay
and then so then this generates all
sorts of different heroes because
there's different ways of him being
successful then you have a panoply of
heroes then you think okay well now
we've got all those heroes that's a set
we can move pull back and say okay
something about all these heroes is what
makes them heroes
that's when you extract out the
monotheistic Savior okay so that's why
in Christianity Christ is the king of
kings it's actually you can think about
it as a literal statement for forget
about the religious overlay it's like
okay you got a bunch of people some of
them are kind of King like okay so you
admire them it's like for whatever
reason that is it's not easy to figure
out why you admire someone right that's
complicated but let's say you've got
admire admirable people you start
telling stories about them that's why
you go to a movie reni want to watch
someone you don't care about your board
by know you want to go watch someone
admirable and interesting or maybe the
opposite of that but doesn't matter it's
the same thing then you think okay well
we've got all these admirable people
they're generating the world properly
that's what makes them admirable there's
a principle they embody and that
principle is the process by which the
admirable world is generated that's the
logos okay that's the thing that's
operative at the beginning of time so
here's my it say here's my question
about about all this because now we're
really not talking about 12 rules for
life as much as maps meaning which is
your first book which are your doing me
the audio it's it's definitely a harder
book than 12 rules for life in a much
more complex book in a lot of ways than
to
for life so how Universal are these
systems meaning why is it that the
enlightenment only arrives at one time
in human history and one place in human
history as opposed to if human biology
is essentially consistent across you
know across humanity then why is it that
that you know if at the at the apex of
the levels you have the Enlightenment
idea which is when I started this
particular question then why is it that
it only arrives in one place at one time
as opposed to arriving in a variety of
places in a right it's a great question
okay the first thing we would say is the
process by which this the hierarchy
itself and success within the hierarchy
is generated that's to be accounted over
millions of years at least hundreds
thousands of thousands of years but I
would push it back because you can see
analogues in the chimps so 20 million
years let's say that's a long time on
that time scale the fact that the
enlightenment values arose in Europe 500
years ago before anywhere else it's like
well who cares it's it's it's five old
men long right if you put five 100 right
old men in line it's like it's yesterday
it's this morning so we've we've evolved
these hierarchical structures that's our
culture we've evolved ways of
maneuvering within the hierarchical
structures that are successful and now
we've started to evolve ways of mapping
our our adaptation not just adapting but
mapping it okay so how does the mapping
occur first admiration second imitation
of admiration and that would be drama
it's like you you dramatize Shakespeare
extracts out what's admirable and
interesting and plays it out so that's
the use of the body as a
representational structure of the body
so we act out what's admirable they
think okay now we've kind of got to
drama down we're all captured by this
drama it's like well then the literary
critics come along the philosophers and
they say oh what are the principles by
which the admirable people operate it's
like chimps woke up and said oh well
some chimps are more successful than
others what are the rules of success
it's like well there were no rules
because they weren't running by rules
right there aren't rules until you
describe the patterns then you have a
rule okay that's what happens with
by the woman right Moses has a
revelation here's the rules right yeah
we've been living out those rules
forever yeah we didn't know what they
were because they weren't rules they
were customs right okay so you start by
mapping your customs in drama and story
and that way you can represent them and
you can transmit them then once you have
them in your grip say they're
represented now not just acted out well
then you can move one step backwards
from them and you can say well what's
the commonalities among these what are
the general principles that would be the
development of something like the Code
of Hammurabi right it's like well we've
got all these customs what are they
right revelation it's like oh here's how
you map the customs that's the Decalogue
it's the same idea so I took human
beings a very long time to evolve their
hierarchies to evolve their structures
of success and then to have enough
people around with enough spare time to
engage in the cultural process of the
artistic cultural process of mapping the
adaptive structure that only merges in
mythology and drama then that lays the
groundwork for philosophy then the
Philosopher's could come in especially
once it's written like in the
judeo-christian pantheon it's like oh
now we've got it written down oh well we
don't have to remember it right we can
read it and while we're reading we can
think about it and so then out of that
starts to come the semantic codes well
then you get the Enlightenment it's like
oh well here's a bunch of semantic codes
it's like yeah yeah those are great so
this is really interesting because you
know if you read Pinker or three journal
Goldbergs new book essentially they
attribute the the Enlightenment to Jonah
Goldberg calls it the miracle it's
almost as though it accidentally
occurred in a certain place in a certain
time John doesn't quite go quite that
far I think to be fair to him but I
think that that philosophy that this
sort of sprang up randomly here is is
very much embedded in a lot of sam
harris is thinking a lot of queers
thinking and you're taking it further
back but i do wonder if this may be an
area of actual disagreement of us it
should be fun are you attributing the
growth of the judeo-christian ethic that
emerges into the Enlightenment as also
accidental you're just pushing timeline
further back oh I don't think it's axe
okay and I'm not making a reductionist
argument so the first thing is I'm going
to say this is how religion evolved but
I'm not saying I'm not saying that this
explanation exhausts the phenomenon
because it's a very strange phenomenon
it's very very strange but but that
doesn't mean we can't generate a
plausible evolutionary account it's like
if you have a bunch of motivated
emotional limited beings occupying the
same territory and competing and
cooperating for the same resources
including the resource of cooperation
which can generate more resources is not
a zero-sum game there are going to be
patterns of adaptation that emerge from
that that are similar so here's a way of
thinking about it if you put a bunch of
kids together they're gonna evolve games
right well which games well a bunch of
different games yeah but they're all
games right so even though so that's the
moral relativist element a bunch of
different games okay but the moral
absolutist element is yeah yeah but
they're all games and the games have to
be playable which means they have to
continue right in an iterated way right
so that's a big constraint people have
to want to play them so not only do they
have to be games know and comprehensible
to everybody and enjoyable but people
but they have to be self maintaining and
everyone has has to want to play them
okay that's the answer to the postmodern
conundrum a plethora of potential
ethical implications of the world an
infinite variety yeah okay fine not an
infinite variety of pragmatically
applicable interpretations you instantly
constrain the universe - Walter - what
well this is why there's commonalities
in mythologies it's like if you put
enough people together in enough
different places the commonality of the
groups of people there because of the
grounding and common motivation and
emotion and embodiment because were
embodied means that they're going to
generate hierarchies that are broadly
similar with strategies of success
within those hierarchies that are
broadly similar with descriptions of the
strategies that are broadly similar and
so you could say in some sense the ethic
that gave rise to the Enlightenment
is in place more or less everywhere now
it's tricky because not every
hierarchical system is as functional as
every other hierarchical system some of
them can degenerate into tyranny we're
talking about the set of all voluntarily
playable games right or something like
that and that can degenerate out of that
you're gonna get common hero myths you
have to and then and then that lays the
groundwork that lays the groundwork for
even our ability to communicate right
right so this is the Enlightenment guys
they just they're not getting that so
and this gets to I think a the broader
question that I know you and Sam went on
for three hours about about the nature
of truth because particularly truth in
the moral sphere I think that you know
I'm would be fair to say that you guys
agree on the idea of truth in the
scientific sphere that you know if
something is that there is such a thing
as objective truth or are you I would
say we agree on a lot of that that the
question is to some degree why do
scientists accept the idea that
objective truth is true and then I would
say we probably don't agree about that
because I would ground that in
pragmatism right and Sam would ground
out in the idea of an independently
existing objective world right which is
a leap of faith more like my own
actually than the pragmatist view right
no and if you believe that there's a god
who's out there in the universe who
created the structures in a particular
certain way then what he created is the
truth and it is apart from you that
human beings didn't exist and they
weren't able to utilize the truth that
truth would still exist out there
whereas the pragmatist I'd say its truth
is in the use that it has for you well
that exact thing is that you know I
don't know if we would consider a
scientific truth true unless we are also
simultaneously accepting the idea that
scientific truth is good for people so
there's one other thing I wanted to
bring up that's relevant because you
brought up the idea of God so here's a
way of thinking about it and and I don't
know what to make of this because this
is stretching me this is stretching my
thoughts out beyond where I've been able
to develop them so this is the intuition
that I have based on a variety of things
experiences I've had so imagine that
there's a very wide range of human
behaviors okay and some subset of those
are both admirable and not admirable so
let's call them good and evil at this at
the extremes okay then we might say well
there's a pad
that characterizes all the actions that
are good and a pattern that
characterizes all the actions that are
evil and that's a transpersonal pattern
because it's not just about you or me
it's about everyone okay and so then
that gets personified
that's Christ and Satan let's say or
Cain and Abel right that gets
personified and that's a bad guy and a
good guy in a movie like its its
personified all the time it's Thor and
Loki you know in the Marvel movies you
know so now you have the odd state you
take the idea of Christ and you think
okay so that's the abstraction of
everything that's that's admirably good
about the set of all human behaviors
okay and then you think well what sort
of reality does not have and this
Bissman pulls back into the reality of
the idea of the logos and the idea that
it was the logos that God used at the
beginning of time to extract order out
of chaos so you think well it's
transpersonal the goodness because it's
not just characterized stick of any one
person it's more like something that
inhabits a person other than that a
person is you can really see this for
example on the other end - with a
satanic end because if you read the
writings of people who do absolutely
horrific things like the shooters you
can see that possession and
extraordinarily clearly if your eyes are
open it's like and it's shocking so
people don't usually look at it and they
even say that themselves like that the
Columbine kids their writings are
hair-raising you know and they were
clearly possessed by an evil that you
only encounter if you sit in a dark
place and brood on your hatred for
months and years right you go places
that you go places where all the dark
people go right right and then that if
that takes you over okay so the good can
take you over as well okay so there's
this there's the spirit of good let's
say and what the spirit of good does is
act in the world on the potential of the
world to generate the actuality of the
world and the judeo-christian
proposition is is that if you confront
the potential of the world with good in
mind using truth truthful communication
then the order that you extract is good
and then that's echoed in
Genesis when God is using the word and
he creates cosmos out of potential and
every time he does that he says and it
was good which is I think it's so
interesting because there's a
proposition there in the proposition
there is that if you encounter potential
with truth the cosmos you create is
actually good well that's that's just an
absolutely overwhelming idea it's like
if it's true if it's true it's the
greatest idea there ever was ya know
your your thoughts on this actually from
maps of meaning help generate what we in
injury's him clubs VAR torah in hebrew
meaning they thought about that about
the the bible but it this merged with a
little bit versus italian thought led me
to the idea that when it comes to the
mystical notion of the tree of good and
evil in in eden what is that supposed to
be what did what did people do wrong by
eating from the tree of good and evil
and my feeling is that what they did
wrong is that god created a universe in
which the value was embedded in the
object right then in the same way that
you in your in your book talk about if
you're teaching a child about an object
the rules of the object are embedded in
the teaching about the object so you use
the example of a vase we're discussing
this earlier but you use the example of
a vase where you teach a child don't
touch the base because the base will
break so that the rule is embedded in
the object in the same way in a wrist
italian thought the rules for behavior
are embedded in the nature of the
universe
meaning what makes a man good is what
makes a man unique which is the reason
the idea is the reason is what makes man
unique so acting in accordance with
right reason is what makes something is
what makes an action good so if you
believe that God created the universe
along these lines and that what natural
law is is just a human attempts to
understand the lines along which created
God created the universe then we're
human beings went wrong is when they
decided to separate values from the
universe when we decided to take values
and say this is a completely separate
thing so this base has no rules attached
to it anymore it's just a vase and we
can construct the rules arbitrarily as
to what to do with this vase and so
eating from the tree of knowledge of
good and evil changes the nature of good
and evil from the universe comes along
with a set of rules to human beings
think that they can use their own
intuitions who supplant God's rules and
to supplant universal rules with their
own particular vision of what the
universe ought to be and at that point
they have to be expelled yeah well ok ok
so that's also associated to some degree
I would say with milk
warning in paradise laws because Milton
basically portrays Lucifer who's the
bringer of light weirdly enough as the
spirit of unbridled rationality which
accounts for to say the Catholic Church
antagonism the Catholic Church's
antagonism towards rationality the idea
was same idea and the Tower of Babel
that human beings have a proclivity to
erect their own dogmatic ethical systems
and then to expand them into a
grandiosity that challenges the
transcendent and that that's a
totalitarian catastrophe and for Milton
Satan was the spirit that eternally does
that right who says everything I know is
enough and that's the plants what I
don't know that's the plants that
transcendent and that that's a
catastrophe how that's tangled up with
thee with the knowledge of good and evil
while you're making some headway towards
towards sorting that out I mean there is
a cataclysm that's that's explained in
in in the story of Adam and Eve right
the Cataclysm is the coming to to
wakefulness and its associated partly
with recognition of nakedness which is
recognition of vulnerability and
mortality and the discovery of death and
then also the discovery of good and evil
that goes along with that so you said
well that's partly the the cognitive
division of ethics from the facts of the
object so I have to think that through I
would also recommend to people I think I
mentioned this before is in McGilchrist
book that the master is emissary because
he looks at this neural psychologically
right and and looks at the the left
hemisphere as the hemisphere that's
dealing with the explicitly axiomatic
systems and the right hemisphere that's
dealing with what those systems are
embodied in okay so part of what happens
with with the emergence of good and evil
is as far as I could tell it took me a
long time to think about this is that
and this is different than the than the
hypothesis that you laid forward which
is why I can't reconcile it exactly yes
you recognize you're naked you know you
can be hurt you know you're vulnerable
and insufficient you hide from God
because that's what happens next
and the reason you hide from God say God
is your destiny or God is the you're
walking with God is a manifestation of
your ultimate proper destiny you you
doubt whether you're capable
of that because now you realize your
embodied finitude your nakedness and
insufficiency so you hide in your
ashamed so there's that you also realize
that you can be hurt and suffer and that
kind of goes along with God's command
that you're going to work in the sweat
of your brow and that you're going to
die and that women are gonna be
subjugated to men which is put on as a
curse not as a moral imperative right
right um but then what emerges out of
that is that as soon as you you know
that you can be hurt
this is what differentiates us from
animals and you really think that
through here's all the myriad ways I can
be hurt
then you're angry about that because you
can be hurt but even worse you can
figure out how to hurt other people and
and so that's part of that knowledge of
good and evil you associated with this
dissociation of the of the object from
its ethical container right now the
universe has created by God from our
interpretation of the universe that
there is a gap between the two and that
once human beings begin to supplant
their own rationality for a tea house
right in the versatility Lee ology you
know we end up doing is creating all
sorts of awful systems that end up
destroying us in the other stuff but
there's something about that that's
right I mean part of what happens in the
New Testament as far as I can tell is
that what Christ says so he's trying to
transcend the rule structure might not
because there's anything wrong with the
rules they're necessary precondition for
discipline which is actually why I wrote
12 rules right he's like you need rules
but they're but rules conflict and they
don't always apply and so there has to
be an ethic underlying the rules and you
should have more respect for the ethic
than for the rules right okay Christ's
idea and this is part of the idea of the
reestablishment of paradise is that you
should orient yourself towards the good
and that's something like an alliance
with God and then that you should tell
the truth and that's that's the ethic
that generated the rules to begin with
okay and then we could be serious about
this you know and we could say well how
do you adjudicate the reality of that
claim alright so then we might think
we're we already walked through the fact
that the heroes of the past acted on
potential to extract out the world of
actuality and if they did that properly
then the world they extracted was good
and that that is a divine principle and
then we might say well is it a divine
principle onion
say well what is it that's acting
through people in the good like the
Christian theological answer to that
would be the Logans right right that's
the idea that's the idea of the holy
spirit roughly speaking right might
think well is that a real thing it's
like well to me
it's real the same way that
consciousness is real and we don't know
the role of consciousness in determining
reality even but even if you're an
evolutionary biologist and this is so
interesting because the evolutionary
biologists actually discriminate
differentiated themselves from Darwin on
this point like Darwin was very very
forthright in his claim that sexual
selection was as powerful as natural
selection or even more so and so that so
here's where this back toes and and
because that was because that brought
consciousness into the world as an
active player the materialistic
evolutionary biologist ignored that so
like 150 years and only concentrated on
natural selection where they could play
well this is all chance right it's like
sexual selection is not chance okay so
here's a hypothesis human being
separated themselves from chimpanzees
one of the reasons they did that was
because human females are sexually
selective chimps aren't chimps will
female chimps in estrus will mate with
any chimp the Maine chimps the dominant
ones chased the subordinate males away
so they're more likely to have offspring
but it's not because of female choice
right now female human females have done
this whole different thing is that
they've they've they have hidden
fertility and they're much more likely
to go after guys who have climbed up the
hierarchy so let's say heroes will give
the women some credit for intelligence
right and say that that's what they're
after even if they're using wealth and
so forth and status as a marker they're
actually using those as a marker for
competence standed yeah and I think
that's I think the evidence I think the
evidence for that is clear okay so you
might say oh well it was human female
conscious choice that selected us mm-hmm
okay and you think well that's not
random that's not random at all it's the
farthest thing from random that there is
and that means consciousness is making
its choices with regards to what
propagates but then it's even more
complex than that so here's what happens
among men the men all get together in
their hierarchy
they positive valued goal they all
accept that as the goal because
otherwise they wouldn't be cooperating
right then they arranged themselves into
a hierarchy and they let the most
confident guys lead because they want to
get to they want to get to the promised
land they want to get it the most
competent leaders leading Rea competent
defined by that value okay so here's
what happens essentially the men all get
together and vote on the good man
and the good man are then chosen by the
women and those are the people who
propagate and so it's like men are
voting on which men get to reproduce and
women are going along with the vote and
and and being even more stringent in
their in their choices let's say and so
then what you get is that the
consciousness that through its active
expression transforms the potential of
the world into actuality also selects
the direction of evolution right and
that's where the meme darkens term turns
into the biological reality it's not so
it yeah this is something that's so cool
about Dawkins it's like I've often
thought this about Dawkins is if he
would push his thinking to the limits he
would fall right into you well and then
he'd be lost that's a whole other
universe but if you think that mean
seriously like and I mean really
seriously think yeah there's some ways
of conceptualizing that becomes so
all-encompassing
yeah that's right they start to become
an actual force of evolution itself and
so then here's the case you could make
consciousness extracts the proper world
of being from potential through truth
and then it's good okay that's our hard
one man that manifests itself in human
beings at the individual level of
individual consciousness that's the
logos within
that's the metaphysical foundation of
the idea of natural right and
responsibility that's a bloody killer
idea that's expressed in the hero of
Heroes that idea that hero of Heroes is
the driving force behind human evolution
so not only do you get the action of the
logos metaphysically as the process that
extracts order out of chaos at the
beginning of time you also get it as the
me
driver of evolution and so then he last
okay then what kind of reality does that
have because you chase consciousness
back and like it disappears into the
mystery of our past and we have no idea
what its relationship is with matter but
it's the force that gives rise to the
cosmos and drives evolution it's like
you're getting pretty close to God there
yeah even just pragmatically speak and
you're certainly you know not close to
but in the midst of it of an argument
about freewill because obviously if you
if you make the hard determinist
argument that free will doesn't exist
and the consciousness is merely a sort
of trick that your brain is playing on
itself then how exactly does how does
culture propagate how do we how do these
memes propagate how are people choosing
hmm sexual selection of natural
selection become one of the same as soon
as you boil sexual selection down to
natural selection oh you know so I think
the freewill argument I mean I see why
Harris gets tangled up in that you know
because well first of all deterministic
arguments are unbelievably powerful and
when we use deterministic models for
many things they really were right so
you could say well we're gonna use that
by defaults like fair enough we're gonna
deviate from that with care but I don't
see people as driven like clocks winding
down first of all we don't wind down in
any simple way we're dissipative
structures to use he wrote Schrodinger
what is life a human being is a
dissipative structure we're not we're
not an entropic structure like a clock
running down we are in some sense but as
living beings we pull energy in and so
we're not winding down like a
deterministic structure or something
other than that and the way we treat
each other is as logos as far as I can
tell the way I treat myself right if I'm
going to be good to myself in the proper
sense is that I'm an active agent of
choice confronting an infinite landscape
of potential and casting that potential
into a reality for good or for evil okay
and if I treat myself that way then I
have proper respect for myself and
proper fear of myself because I can make
bad decisions and warp the structure of
reality and I think if you read Frankel
for example or Solzhenitsyn and you see
how your bad decisions could warp the
structure of reality then that wakes you
up right okay so
there's that if you don't treat yourself
like an an active agent imbued with
logos then your life doesn't go well but
more if you don't treat other people
that way they do not want to play with
you if we set up societies that aren't
predicated on the idea that people are
like that then the societies become they
dissolve or they become totalitarian
almost instantly so then I would say
well you've got the problem of
determinism it's like fair enough man
how do you reconcile the fact that if
you lay out a society at every level of
analysis on strict deterministic grounds
it fails
so doesn't doesn't that mean your
hypothesis has a flaw I mean maybe not
maybe you could say no the facts are
independent of the ethical code right
exactly this is where the truth this is
where the truth pragmatism question
comes back into being written Samos say
well it's true regardless of what the
effect is mhm and you would say well
it's obviously not true if morals aren't
constructed for a pragmatic reason and
if this fragment doesn't work if it
falls into nothing it also it also
depends to some degree on what you're
willing to how you're willing to test
your hypothesis because I might say well
if your hypothesis is factually correct
wouldn't you assume that if people based
their their their their behaviors
individually and familial and socially
on that set of facts which is basically
what Sam claims about facts to do in
with if you base your ethos on that
those facts wouldn't it work right well
he claims that that's a test you know I
would say well then it fails that test
yeah it doesn't work we have to treat
each other like divine Centers of
consciousness in order for society to
work yes I think well that's I can't see
any way out of those arguments yeah III
can't see there obviously which is why
you and I agree on so much about this
kind of stuff and I think that it's also
the reason why people find your work
really inspiring you know while the left
wants to claim that you are an angry
person they'll claim similarly that I'm
a deeply angry to person I don't think
it's been quite an angry conversation
I'm pretty sure it has not been but I'm
horrified by what the radical left is
capable of but that doesn't make me
angry exactly and and I think that it's
it's demonstrative of why so many people
find what you're doing inspiring because
unlike the radical left which is
consumed with the idea of victimhood and
victimology and we're victims of the
system like Marxism makes the claim that
the only way that people suck is the
claimant Marxism makes but the only way
to cure people of sucking is by changing
the entire system which will in some
magical fashion transform the nature of
humanity yeah in the proper direction
right exactly the claim that you're
making and I hope that I'm making as
well is that human beings do suck unless
they decide you stop sucking mm-hmm
right and then and your whole goal is to
tell people exactly how it is that they
can clean up their rooms near Venice
race Gus yeah well they might as well
start with what's right in front of them
it's a lot harder than it looks because
to clean up your room means to accept
that it's actually necessary for you to
take that little bit of
chaos that's in front of you that
chaotic potential and cast it into
habitable order and then you have to
develop the right attitude towards that
it's like okay well I'm gonna put my
room in order well what do you mean
order is in relationship to something
you know like if your desk is ordered it
means you've ordered it because you're
going to work there and you're working
there on something valuable and so the
order is conceived of in relationship to
a Telos it's like okay you're gonna
order your room well what are you gonna
do in it
like what's your room for what's the
purpose what's the purpose you can't or
to your room without falling into
purpose and I would say well if you're
gonna fall into purpose it's like try it
out on a local scale first right you
don't want to go out there and change
the system it's like what the hell do
you know leave the system alone see what
you can do locally see if you can put
yourself together see if you can put
your immediate environment together and
you'll find if you're in a chaotic
household and a chaotic household would
be one where no one has any discipline
no one has any aims and there's a
terrible battle between Cain and Abel
going on all the time right so so life
sucks and everything's miserable and
we're cynical and that's what wisdom is
it's like and there's no point trying
anything because everything is
meaningless and who the hell is gonna
care in a million years and you're a
fool to move forward in any case it's
like there's your household okay and so
now you decide no despite all that I'm
going to put my room in order it's like
you will have a war on your hands
because the first thing the people
around you who are aiming down will do
is think oh you really ate you think
you're so much better than we are
do you you really think that you and
your fancy goddamn plans it's like we're
gonna put every psychological obstacle
we can possibly think of in your way
because if you succeed even in something
that trivial you shed a very dim light
on our existence and so we're gonna put
we're gonna do everything we can to take
you out and so this people think oh well
it's cleaning your room that's just too
cliche it's like yeah really I just go
ahead and try it you see how much of a
cliche that is and if you've got your
room in order then put your office in
order see and then you're going to
encounter the as soon as you do that you
step out into the social world you're
gonna encounter the antipathy between
men and women you're gonna
the identity politics in the workplace
you're gonna encounter how you regulate
your sexual morality while you're
working with people of the opposite sex
you're gonna encounter the ethics that
are necessary to move your business
forward it's like the whole it's a
microcosm it really is and so to take
those micro causes meant cause them
seriously well that's what I'm asking
people to do and I'm saying look it
isn't only about you being happy it's
like yeah whatever HAP there's lots of
times in your life you're not going to
be happy and so that's not gonna work
you want to have something meaningful
that's the boat that will take you
through the storm
right when you batten down the hatches
but there's more it isn't even that it
isn't even me a meaningful engaged life
will see you through the catastrophes
even though that's a big deal right
that's a great proposition and I really
believe it's true because you can say to
yourself yeah it's worth it right right
and it's great and but there's the other
part of it too which is don't be
thinking that your errors aren't linked
to hell because they are if you look at
what happened in the 20th century the
brilliant commentators on the on the
20th century totalitarian states and all
of their atrocities said the same thing
over and over
it isn't top-down evil leader
manipulating innocent masses that's not
it it's the moral failings of every
single individual unwilling to say their
truth unwilling to act out what they
know to be right that accumulate and
produced the catastrophic state and so
when you're fussing about with your life
when you're not manifesting your
potential when you're falsifying your
speech and your actions in the service
of short-term expedience you are working
to bring about hell on earth and that's
true it's true literally and then it's
true it's I suspect it's also true
metaphorically and that's a real truth
man when you get the literal and the
metaphorical working at the same time
it's like that's that's real so it isn't
just that you have to fix up yourself so
that you know you can have a better life
it's like who cares about you for a
moment you know it's you have to fix up
your life because if you don't every
time you make a mistake
that you know to be a mistake you're
leading the world toward health
and I believe that I think it's true
well Jordan Peterson's book has 12 rules
for life honestly I we could do this all
day long and we'll certainly have you
back I really appreciate the time
there's a reason so many people follow
Jordan there's some reason so many
people are buying this book the book is
fantastic and his other book maps
meeting is also fantastic so go get a
copy of that as well Jordan thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it thanks Ben
it was great yep
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex singhara audio is
mixed by Mike Carr Amina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah Oliveira the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018